how are you Brian hi rich so Scott
Foster's trending right now
on Twitter how do you think the NBA
likes that terrible it's it's a real
commentary on where the league is right
now I mean I think in you know from
30,000 feet the fact that there's so
much attention paid on the NBA and then
officiating assignment and a second
round playoff game can be discussed on
national television and national radio
shows us how far the league has come in
terms of visibility but it's just not a
positive trend and there there is a
coming black eye to the NBA with
officials and teams it has been building
it has been boiling in the last two
weeks we've seen one player throw a ball
an official we've seen a GM go into the
officials locker room we saw Chris Paul
bump an official in Game one for which
he was fined $35,000 the officials are
pushing back which is one of the reasons
the ejections are way up the situation
is boiling right now
and it needs to be turned down for the
good of the game so then how does Scott
Foster get a sign tonight was this
before the playoffs or did did somebody
in the league office after everything
that happened in Game one with the
Rockets reaction to everything to happen
in Game one say let's let's put their
least favorite official on the floor for
Game two how did that happen
yes the officials are the first four
games of every series the officials are
assigned in advance so Scott Foster was
going to be game through the official
whether the Rockets won by 75 points in
Game one
or lost at the end of the game on a foul
call they are putting him early in the
series to leave room for him to come
back late in the series last year he
officiated game 7 of the of the Rockets
warriors series he's 25-year official
this is his 20th playoff he is routinely
ranked among the top 5 to 7 officials
which is why he gets these assignments
and the thing about is rich that
historically if you are a visiting team
you watch Scott Foster there was a
streak a couple of years ago where
visiting teams won 12 consecutive games
in the playoffs and Scott foster with
the official sum
that is just very and some that is just
luck but I do believe that Scott Foster
for the things for the reasons that the
Rockettes hate him
especially what they believe is
arrogance he is not intimidated by a
crowd he will make any call at any time
I think for a visiting team typically
you like to see Scott Foster because you
feel like he will not be pushed around
by the crowd obviously though the
Rockettes don't care where the game is
played they don't want to see Scott
Foster but rich if you were watching and
most fans would never watch it but if
you were watching the officiating
assignments over the last three days
that Foster hadn't worked any second
round games yet and he was on the second
round roster so it was pretty clear he
was either gonna be assigned to
Milwaukee tonight or Oakland tonight the
Rockets knew there was a good
possibility yesterday so they did not
know until today even though these so
the assignments are made but aren't
released to the teams until day of is
that the way it works right yeah that's
been the rule for years the officiating
assignments are announced at 9:00 and
Eastern for every game from the
preseason to the final so how do you
think down Morrie and the rest of the
Rockets took that news this morning
Brian this entire thing is a smoke
screen okay all in elaborate smokescreen
James Harden is in a slump he can't make
a shot
he's shooting 32% over the last four
games
he's shooting 28% from three-point range
he's trying to get the whistle he can't
get it Kevin Durant is shooting 55% over
the last five games and averaging 40
points a game I don't care what official
you have in the entire world over if you
don't turn that around you're not
winning this here the whole thing is a
smokescreen the Rockets are playing
everybody they specialize in finding and
exploiting inefficiency whether that's
the corner three-point shot whether it's
the players that they elect to sign or
to draft or whether it's certain play
calls that they know can where they can
apply pressure to referees specifically
the three-point shot the rules on where
you can land and how you can defend a
three-point shot are
and the rap and the and the Rockets know
this and they take advantage of it just
like they take advantage the corner
three-pointer the strategy is fine but
don't let you look don't for think for a
second that they've been historically
wronged or something
every team gets bad calls every team has
issues with officials by the way the
Warriors do not like Scott Foster a lot
of teams do not like Scott Foster one of
the other guys in this game tonight ed
Malloy ejected Kevin Durant in the last
round so the concept that this is about
Scott foster or whether this is about
the Rockets being wrong is a market
inefficiency that the Rockets are trying
to exploit and they're there and they're
sucking everybody into it they're
smarter than a lot of team and they're
trying to fool people don't let yourself
be fooled
Brian win worst in the Honda inside a
report from ESPN you just said a lot
right there I want to pin it but put a
pin in a couple of things and revisit
but I want to hit right here right now
what I'm sure some Rockets fans are
thinking upon hearing what you just said
the Warriors aren't jumping into the
landing zone of the Rockets you don't
think that they're not taking some bunny
hops and taking advantage of knowing
what the Rockets are trying to do Brian
like like I said the rules are a little
bit vague it is legal for this for the
player who is defending the 3-point shot
to move slightly forward okay and that
is what is happening it is also
sometimes the Rockets are doing where
they ought were hard is specifically
sticking his legs and and going forward
on three-pointers that last
three-pointer that he was upset he
didn't get fouled on harden took off
about three feet behind the three-point
line and his feet landed inside the
three-point line that is not a foul if
you go forward like that now were there
other calls in that game where the
Warriors came up underneath James Harden
absolutely without question there should
have been a couple of plays called was
that the reason that the Rockets lost
the game
no James they're averaging 98 points
again this is a number too often in the
NBA they're averaging 98 points a game
over their last four games their
offenses lost its mojo they got thrown
off their rhythm by by the Jazz
and the Warriors completely took away
the cleanse could tell a lob game he had
a miserable game and harden going for of
16 from three-point range and and then
the capela game being taking it taking
up apart was the reason they lost again
the rest of it is just a smoke screen
there are official calls that happen
both ways in every game that it is that
is part of the flow of the game and you
know you pointing out as well it's not
just a Scott Foster thing with the
Rockets he's gonna be universally
disliked tonight and it's not just a
Scott Foster thing there are other refs
on the floor the history that's going on
all that said don't you think it's odd
that after Chris Paul and the Rockets
made as public as they've ever done
their animus toward Scott foster and
what they think is in the same direction
going the other way that they keep him
away from the Rockets all the way up
until this series I mean I understand
the NBA I mean what what look I know the
league can't let a team just dictate who
refs their games but to keep him away
all this point and then for the biggest
series that these two teams might face
all year long certainly in the mind's
eye of the fans now they decide to
return him to the floor against the
Rockets yeah it's a very very fair
question I don't have the data of you
know for all I know Scott foster didn't
officiate a Utah Jazz game for the first
two months of the season then officiated
eight in the second half I don't have
the data of the average time between
between officiating assignment I do
agree that that is unusual and seems to
me that there may have been something at
play there I do not know how long they
schedule the guys out in the regular
season I think it's a couple of weeks at
a time I agree that that is unusual but
I can't say for sure that that's
anything out of the ordinary and the
regular referee rotation but again I
wrote a story about the officiating last
week where I expected Scott Foster to be
in this series so I'm going to tell you
again if this sucker goes six or seven I
sense that Foster for a second time it
is he is a top-five official no matter
what anybody wants to say they rate
these officials this way and he is there
because of his rating it's not a
surprise to me at all that he is here
and again even when I was with the
Rockets yesterday at their practice they
have been watching knowing
scoffs officer was probably coming and
they were wondering when I was gonna
happen to when they when they when they
saw this Scott foster did not draw a
game yesterday and we were three days
into the second round and there had been
multiple games played at a game in every
Syrian Scott Foster's name hadn't popped
up they knew he was either in Milwaukee
in a hotel room last night or he was in
Oakland in the hotel room last night I'm
telling you they knew it was coming he's
like a meme Foster is coming like Game
of Thrones Foster is coming I mean I
read that piece that you're referring to
about officiating last week on espn.com
it's a great piece I suggest everybody
go read it and in conjunction with a
piece that just got posted in the last
24 hours from your colleague Zach Lowe
and Rachel Nichols about the Rockets
having put together a memo they never
forwarded to the league but they did
express and communicate the contents of
the memo to league looking at game seven
last year between the Rockets and the
wars that Foster did referee saying that
the 8th there were 81 potential missed
calls and Nan calls in game 7 that cost
him at least 18 points on average and
the memo according to this article
essentially accused the referees of of
throwing it ace what so when you talk
about how bad it is getting what the
this seems like it's now reached the
DEFCON level that the Commissioner has
to step in what can be done to tamp down
the argument here March for this you
know the average fan who doesn't do this
for a living I understand why they would
fall for it you're too smart for this
this is a smokescreen where the Rockets
missed 27 consecutive 3-pointers in game
7 James Harden shot 24 percent in the
series on three-pointers there was
another game he had in that series where
he went
oh of 11 from three-point range no they
lost that series for a bunch of
different Reno I know that I'm not
saying that they're that their argument
has merit at all what I'm saying is
they're making it and they're coming up
with
I mean daryl morey is putting his Sloan
MIT to work right here that's right and
putting it in the face of the NBA and
I'm sure he might not be the only team
to do that what I'm saying is it is
ratcheting up your point
is it is is is dead solid on here that
there's a boiling pot there's a lid on
top of it what does the Commissioner
duties you start fining teams for for
even twitching in that direction or what
what can be done here to turn down the
temperature so Scott Foster's not
trending and we're talking about a huge
game to tonight with a different filter
well they're passing out fines left to
right there's been massive fines handed
out in this postseason already you know
there's not a lot of leadership being
shown you know in my opinion by the
people you should be showing the
leadership you know you know Steve Kerr
for example Steve Kerr is it was one of
the most socially conscious and
progressive thinkers in in all of
American sport his voice is super duper
important but he has led his the warrior
the Warriors to me are the most
egregious team in the league right now
about the way they treat officials you
know Kevin Durant and draymond Green has
been out of control of time this year
one of the few ways that you mean again
this is a rockets being smart I mean I'm
I'm just I'm not mad at the Rockets for
trying to do this because they're just
playing the game I'm just trying to get
people's eyes open it's almost
impossible to beat the Warriors four out
of seven ok because they're just too
damn good if they're healthy you know
Steph Curry sprained his ankle and
misses three game that's a different
story
one of the few places where the Warriors
are vulnerable is the way they handle
officials they lose their mind they get
ejected from games they racked up
technicals they racked up flagrant they
get suspensions for their things so the
one of the ways that you can get to the
Warriors is to apply pressure to the
officials and get them thinking more
about the officials and they are about
the opponent and Steve Kerr in my
opinion as good as he has done in
everything else as a leader of the
Golden State Warriors has not done a
good job in setting an example not what
the official officiating bothers them
the Warriors allow the officiating to
bother them and I don't think Steve Kerr
has done a good job to stop it and I
also think that part of the thing that's
happened in the NBA since Adam silver
took over it's been a much more prey
player friendly administration things
that God uses
ended during david stern's era with the
officials now get you find things that
you got fine for during david stir and
now get you down get you nothing it's
been a long time coming and again we're
heading towards a boiling point
like i said just in the last two weeks
we have demar derozan throwing a ball at
an official by the way you know
especially he threw the ball at rich is
it scott the ball he threw the ball
Scott foster so are the Spurs dispersed
being penalized has Beth foster do that
game okay then we had Sean marks again a
very high character person who stalked
the entire Brooklyn Nets team with high
character people it's one of the reasons
but they've made such a good turnaround
it's one of the most admirable teams in
the league Sean marks going into the
officials locker room to complain after
game like the seventh grade parent
chasing arrest to a locker room that's
not high character that's not good
leadership and we've got Chris Paul the
president of The Players Association
bump one of the guys who's supposed to
lead the players bumping and official
it's if Davis sir was he was the
Commissioner he might have suspended
Chris Paul hmm so one can find 35,000
there's no leadership so there's not
good leadership by these by these
influential people so there's no fix is
that what you're saying and that it's
just it's out of control and there's no
way to there's no way to fix I mean if
they fines don't work
it can't be six in one day it's been
we've been heading in this direction but
my concern for the league is that we're
going to have a blow-up here and it's
but I think it's in this series is
particularly ripe for it rich again
because the rot the way the Rockets play
specifically is aimed at applying
pressure to the official they may come
in to every single game their game plan
is three-pointers layups and getting to
the foul line the way James Harden plays
the game is designed to apply pressure
the officials and take advantage of
vagueness in rules to get to the foul
line so any Rockets game is gonna be
somewhat difficult for an official and
that's the other thing no matter what
the Rockets want to say every time they
play a game whether it's in the
preseason or whether it's in the final
or in the finals
they bring a certain baggage to the game
when the officials go over their pregame
plan this is one thing people don't
really realize there's three teams on
every NBA court and then you know half
hour before the game one team's going
over it's game plan the other team's
going over it's game playing and the
referees are in their locker room going
over the game themselves and one of the
things that they say is hey let's be
aware that hardens likes to flop on
three-point shooting and so they are
they are predisposed to keep an eye on
Harden and not let him get away with it
especially at the highest level with
veteran official that was one of the
other things that this audits bogus
thing that the Rockets are using to try
to influence future call did they said
that the veteran officials when they
studied it or more likely to make
incorrect calls against the Rockets as
if the veteran officials are somehow
flawed what really happens there is that
veteran officials know the Rockets you
know schemes and game plans and
trickeration and they come into the game
not letting them get away with it as
much the man Brian not to say that
that's not to say they don't miss calls
rich but this is a multi-layered thing
that the Rockets are trying to say look
at the surface but it's actually much
deeper before I let you go quickly ask
him the poll question Chris that's out
there today on the right yeah Brian
three teams down oh one who's got the
best chance to come back Bucs rockets
Blazers what do you think well the the
Bucks were the number one team in league
for a reason this year although you
could see their inexperience in Game one
so I'll say the Bucs
but Boston has to feel pretty good about
Brian thanks for the call appreciate it
I will ask you about more about your
book next time you're on LeBron Hank the
making of a billion dollar athlete that
was released earlier this month let's
chat down the line and a couple weeks
always enjoy our chats immensely thank
you thank you met that's Brian one or
stat win worst ESPN for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app